joining us today the former CIA director
former Secretary of State and the Trump
Administration Mike Pompeo out with a
new book and it is right here it's
called never give an inch Mr secretary
thanks for the time Brad it's great to
be with you thanks for having me on
today
read a large part of the book and it's a
fascinating read what's what's your
biggest takeaway from this process I've
written a few books on history but not
on my personal experience as much
um your your takeaway
oh a couple things so I tried to write
the history as accurately as I could
reflect it I tried to prioritize those
things that really mattered you know a
bunch of things that ended up on The
Cutting Room floor just didn't think it
wasn't that I was trying to hide them it
was just I didn't think they uh they
told the story of trying inside an
establishment foreign policy world uh
working to break glass in a way to kept
the American people safe and I want to
tell some good stories too it's personal
always when you tell them it's from my
point of view what I saw
it's also about the only one that could
tell the span of the whole four years a
lot a lot of turnover in the National
Security team and wanted to make sure
that we covered the challenges we faced
day one and the way way went out the
door on January 20th 2021 and bookend
how we always put the American people
first and it was a lot of fun to write I
think it's fun to read too uh it was a
little bit better before the CIA cleared
it uh but it's still it's still got some
great spy stories as well well speaking
of which you know whenever a former
official writes a book there is always
that possibility of classified
information
and we are seeing that real time I mean
we don't know why then Vice President
Biden did what he did now we have vice
president Pence who has classified
documents that were found at his his
home what's your thought on all of this
and are you sure you don't have any
classified documents at home
well I'm pretty darn sure Brett but I
guess vice president Pence was probably
sure too
uh let's let's be clear every one of us
who handles lots and lots of classified
information has a responsibility to
handle it exactly is the way we'd agreed
we would when you find it in a place it
shouldn't be to turn it in and then
figure out what went wrong to make sure
that that doesn't happen again uh
whether you're president Trump or
President Biden or vice president Pence
or an E5 I wrote about this never give
an inch uh oftentimes classified
information in the hands of young
soldiers or young Sailors or gs12 they
get punished more than senior leaders
who mishandle classified information we
should treat everybody equally it
shouldn't be politics you shouldn't raid
the home of one person and not another
and then every leader has a
responsibility to try and get it right
and if you make a mistake own the
mistake
so now we're looking at vice president
Pence he came forward uh said it was one
box and said that it was a hurried
transition
um and that he contacted the FBI right
away
um how do you see that in the panoply of
what we've learned from vice president
now President Biden and the former
president Trump
still think we don't know enough about
any of these three situations to figure
out what the different fact patterns are
one of the things I regret president
Trump President Biden but neither have
been as transparent as they could be
right here's what happened here's how it
got here here's what I knew here's what
I didn't know full story not from the
spokesperson not for himself but from
them here's what I did here's my role
and by the way
um don't hand it off to somebody who was
on your team you you own that every
leader owns these things and so you
shouldn't say you don't have any regrets
oh boy I'll tell you what if somebody
found some documents that I had put in
the wrong place at some point in time uh
I would regret it uh because I would
have perhaps risked something that was
really important and so I'm not perfect
no one's perfect but boy when you see
something that you got wrong own it fix
it take responsibility for it and then
put process into play so it doesn't
happen again it's it's that
straightforward you mentioned the CIA
process for people who don't know
um what is that process like
Brett I submitted the transcript the
manuscript for review to the Central
Intelligence Agency to the state
department and to the Biden White House
to the White House the National Security
Council each of them conducted a review
they provided comments uh things they
didn't want me to say a lot of times
wasn't classified just hey we'd prefer
you not talk about this for a host of
reasons uh we a little bit of back and
forth but we landed in a place and
ultimately they all signed off on the
manuscript
what do you think your biggest
success was in office and maybe biggest
regret
oh goodness from a process perspective
I'm incredibly proud of how I took the
CIA from where director Brennan had it
uh where they refused to talk about
spying uh that they were focused on
things not adjacent to the mission right
things like diversity Equity inclusion
and lines on a chart and took it back to
the days of the OSS where we were out
doing great work tell these young kids
these young men and women put a dagger
in your mouth get out there do something
for America we took a lot of risk and
delivered really good outcomes really
good outcomes with our partners like
Mossad and Israel and there's some great
stories about the work we did against
Iran uh really good work countering
threats all across the world
uh and I'm proud of that we we literally
took the culture at the CA and flipped
the switch and president Trump was fully
supportive of that uh in foreign policy
two things uh we made clear to the world
that the Chinese Communist party is the
biggest threat to our understanding of
the way we live in the world today and
began to fix it and second they they
told us it was impossible to create
peace in the Middle East until you solve
the problem of the Palestinian conflict
and we said that's a uh that's a Croc we
we created peace agreements between four
nations in Israel we pushed back against
Iran I don't have a security detail
today because of that but we got the
Middle East right and the great news
Brett is it's not just about the Middle
East if you live in Arizona or you live
in Missouri or you live in Idaho you're
safer today and the chance that one of
your kids or your family members or a
friend who's in the army or the Marines
will have to go fight and die in that
place in the Middle East is lower today
and I'm incredibly proud of each of
those two accomplishments China is a
real threat and we made peace in the
Middle East
biggest regret do you have one oh yes we
ultimately weren't successful at getting
the nuclear weapons out of the hands of
Jeremy Kim and never given into I talk
about the first trip I took there on
Good Friday coming back on Easter 2018
uh remarkable trip uh studying the
course for our negotiations with
chairman Kim and while we got the
remains of 50 Americans home I got to
bring three hostages on one of whose
stories told first person in the book
you get to hear his own words it's
really amazing about the greatness of
America uh but we and we got him to stop
testing long-range missiles no nuclear
tests but he still has his nuclear
weapons and I I regret we weren't able
to make more progress there he made
mention of the security detail the
reason you have that is because Iran uh
has made specific threats based on the
killing of solomoni their top General
over there and it's not just you there
are others but how has that changed
obviously you had security detail before
but it's not like this how has that
changed your day-to-day
oh goodness Brett normally when you
leave service no former cabinet members
ever had security before I think I think
Georgetown had a little bit after he
left at CIA but I'll probably have this
so long as the regime in Iran continues
to exist
look it impacts you but a great team
that's keeping me safe uh and so it
doesn't it doesn't impact the way I
interact with the world I'm out there
now they also importantly bright keep
the people who are around me safe too
when I go to big gatherings when I'm in
speaking to groups or out meeting with
people it keeps everyone that's around
me safe as well uh it does make it a
little harder to go to 7-Eleven at
midnight and get cough syrup yeah I
think there's day Susan thinks I use it
as an excuse
but the truth is
um we have we have both determined and
we and I say we both Susan and I both
determined we've done the right thing
we've served the strike on costume
suleimani was righteous I am confident
it saved American lives and whatever
small impact it might have on my life it
was worth it
you know
you may make a decision to go into a
race that gets you to another Secret
Service detail
um when do you think you're going to
make that decision to run for president
or not yeah Brad it's a it's a
reasonable question
I figure sometime in the late spring or
early summer Susan and I are praying
about it we're doing the things one
might do to try and get yourself ready
for that but we haven't ultimately made
the decision it's it's quite an
audacious thing to think that you ought
to be president of the greatest nation
in the history of civilization and you
want to make sure that you not only have
it right in terms of the things you
believe and the policies that you're
going to put forward the arguments
you're going to make to the American
people but also Brad importantly uh that
you're not wolf tweeting right you are
literally prepared to deliver that to
execute it and one of the things I saw
in four years in the Trump
Administration is we were slow and late
getting our team on the field and while
we broke some glass there was a lot more
work to do that next conservative
president has got to be prepared to go
in there on day one and get his team on
the field and begin to actually put
these policies in place so they can't be
undone by the next president as a good
deal of the work that we did in our
Administration has been undone
former U.N Ambassador former South
Carolina Governor Nikki Haley suggested
to me that she believed she could be
that person she went as far as she's
ever gone very close to saying that she
is in fact running for president uh and
I brought up some of the things you
wrote about in this book about
Ambassador Haley and
you know that maybe she was trying to
angle for vice president Pence's job
that she left really soon uh from that
U.N Ambassador job you stand by
everything in the book when it comes to
Nikki Haley right
I do everything I said is true and
accurate
and what do you think about her
prospects uh as she's seems to be
heading towards running for president
uh anyone who believes that they're the
right person for the moment how to go
make the case and in the end the good
people of Iowa New Hampshire and South
Carolina sorted out at the front end and
then 50 states will sort it out at the
back end she'll have to make that
decision for herself but you know Brett
the truth is my the part of my book the
part I never give an inch where I
mentioned Ambassador Haley uh really
wasn't about that little story We
suffered from the fact that we had a lot
of people who didn't want to serve in
the Trump Administration it was hard
work you should know lots of my friends
were saying Mike run everything that
Trump touches turns to to Ash you have
your reputation don't don't hang out
there uh and there were a lot of folks
who took that and left and either didn't
join the administration or when the
going got tough they just walked away
from it and that hurt us that was wasn't
about the who wasn't about the name it
was about our mission to serve the
United States of America and you know as
for me uh I'd hear that and I say thanks
I appreciate your appreciate your wisdom
but I'm the secretary of state or I'm a
sand director whatever I'm a secretary
for the United States of America for
goodness sake I'm not going to give up a
single second of my opportunity the
privilege I've been given to try and
make life better for the American people
you were gonna you're gonna have to
throw me out and I suppose I could have
been fired but I wasn't gonna quit and
so every day I got up put my helmet on
tried to separate the noise from the
signal and tried to deliver for America
and those folks who just decided they
didn't want to be part of that they
didn't want to serve because who the
president was or decided they wanted to
leave while we still have lots and lots
of work to do it's just not about team
that's that's about something different
I'm not going to go too too far down
this road but
um if you decide to run you could hear
former president Trump uh saying you
know what Mike worked for me okay he was
huge he was good but he wasn't me all
right doesn't fill a stadium
I don't get to do that on the show that
much but um I figured I'd give you that
the uh you could hear that that was
world class bro how do you counter that
uh the encounter with the truth uh and
you counter it with making arguments
it's not about Mike Pompeo it is not
about Donald Trump it's about America
uh I I was you know the Washington Post
ran a story that said I was President
Trump's most loyal Cabinet member and he
called me and said Mike The Washington
Post said you might I won't do the
invitation I'll leave that to you he
said he says
you're my most loyal Cabinet member
Mr President that was
that was a compliment
he said you know you're right and hung
up
I certainly served him but I was serving
the American people so if there's a
campaign and president Trump makes that
argument uh I'll I'll smile I've heard
him say it's disloyal it is never just
loyal when you believe that you offer
something to the American people to
profit that and to make the case and
then they'll get this sorted out
one of the things you talk about in the
book uh it was controversial which was
the Saudi relationship and uh obviously
it soured
um and it was a tough moment uh it was a
very interesting moment on a
geopolitical sense when Jamal khashoggi
was was killed and it pointed back uh to
the Saudis directly
you say in the book that khashoggi was
not just some journalist that he was an
activist and had ties to the Muslim
Brotherhood
that set off uh Fred Ryan the publisher
of the Washington Post and he he put out
a statement today saying it is shocking
disappointing to see Mike pompeo's book
so outrageously misrepresent the life
and work of Washington Post columnist
Jamal khashoggi as a CIA as the CIA
which Pompeo once directed concluded
Jamal was brutally murdered on the
orders of Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman his only offense was exposing
corruption and oppression among those in
power uh work that good journalists
around the world do every day goes on to
say that it's a ploy to sell books he's
the publisher and CEO of the Washington
Post and I just want you to respond to
that and you know what you think about
what you said in the book and and that
reaction to it
well lots to say I'm unsurprised the
Washington Post went on a major mission
uh to uh to undermine the work that we
were trying to do to keep America safe
in our relationship with Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia they took out full page ads
fair enough they're free to do that
maybe they're just selling newspapers
Brett but I actually that's just kind of
a joke uh to suggest I wrote that to
sell books is cynical and indecent uh
and immoral and I regret that they did
that I didn't write that to sell books I
wrote that to explain how we were
thinking about keeping the American
people safe
we were very clear the murder of Jamal
khashoggi was heinous and we sanctioned
13 Saudis for what they did there we
also knew that the life of Mr khashoggy
Noir of any individual is more important
than saving lots of American lives that
includes our soldiers Sailors Airmen and
Marines all across the world and in the
Middle East who are defending us the
security relationship between the
America and the United and the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia is an incredibly
important one and so while we held the
Saudis accountable we knew that that
relationship mattered an awful lot and
it's fascinating now to look at this now
a couple years and by the you're right
it was a difficult time uh it was it was
a hard decision to make because you'd
had someone murdered and No One's Gonna
No One's Gonna say no that's okay we
didn't say that was okay but you know a
couple years on it's fascinating to
watch President Biden says well because
of that they're a pariah Nation remember
this it's not that long ago and that has
to go on bended knee to the kingdom
begging for the Saudis to produce oil to
get him out of a political fix that he
was in we were never naive about the
reality of the world it is indeed a
nasty brutal place and our function
every Daybreak was to do our level best
to deliver security and prosperity for
the American people and that meant an
important relationship with the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia we were going to coach
them cajoled them urged them to be
better actors on human rights
but we got this relationship right and
in the end it not only delivered a
better relationship with the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia but you would not have the
Abraham Accords the peace agreements
between Arab states and Israel saving
how many American lives for kids who
won't have to go fight and die in that
place because we brought peace to the
Middle East you can't have it both ways
you can't tell the Arab Nations boy
you're not behaving right and then
demand that they make peace with the
nation of Israel we have the right end
of this we had the right end of the
stick on this one I'm very proud of the
work that we did yeah but but your other
point was that essentially he was not
just a pure columnist for the Washington
Post
it was more complicated than that it was
far more complicated this is a man who
praised Osama Bin Laden when he passed
away right it's just it's we could spend
a lot of time going into the details
most of them are public but suffice it
to say uh this this wasn't somebody
working for the uh Wichita Eagle
covering soccer games this was he he was
he was a multi-faceted person but that
that none of that none of that's
intended to diminish the fact that he
was murdered just simply to say that
this is a complicated problem set in a
complicated part of the world and
America's function in that is that we
weren't responsible for killing him our
responsibility is to make sure that we
saved American lives and I am confident
that we did that mm-hmm
um as you look at the world stage and
and you take yourself from the Middle
East and you go to the the Far East and
China you've talked before about the
threat from China not only long term but
short term
um do you think that Xi Jinping is
watching closely what's happening in
Ukraine as to what China does in Taiwan
Bretton in the book you never given in
to actually talk about the the inner in
a relationship between these conflicts
uh there's no doubt that XI xingping is
watching what's happening in Ukraine uh
probably causes him to question whether
his generals and Admirals are lying to
him like Putin's were lying to him so
he's probably double checking what he's
really got under the hood
but he is also watching How the West
behaves will they stay unified when a
Sovereign Nation is invaded will they
actually provide them with the tools to
defend themselves not just to get a
quagmire or a stalemate but to actually
Crush their adversaries no I I think
he's watching this very closely and it
provides yet another good reason for the
American people to support giving the
ukrainians the tools that they need to
defend themselves
so when you hear uh people in your party
say you know what it's too much we've
we've got to secure the Border we've got
to build schools we've got to fix
infrastructure in the U.S
why are we giving all this money
um to this cause and there is a growing
faction especially in House Republicans
who say that out loud what do you say
yes many of these are my friends Brett I
was part of the conservative group in
the House of Representatives for six
years I know a lot of these folks who
are saying that I think they just
misunderstand the risk to the United
States of America from Vladimir Putin's
successful invasion of Europe that is a
bad outcome for people in Iowa and South
Carolina and New Hampshire it's really
really bad it'll raise prices it'll mess
up our economy it'll tell you something
he's got a green light I could go on uh
I understand their sentiment when they
say boy we should fix our border sign me
up for that never given in she talks
about how I was at the center of doing
that during the Trump Administration we
should fix our schools sign me up for
that too but these aren't Mutual
exclusive options America has the
capacity to do each of these things and
the real risk to the United States of
failing to get this right is a Vladimir
Putin on the March through Europe and at
some point at some point someone asking
for us to send the 82nd Airborne or
Marine rifle Division I do not want to
reach that point it's why we spent so
much trying time to sharing Vladimir
Putin from doing what he did to Joe
Biden attacking a European country on
his watch it didn't happen on hours and
we should make sure now that we provide
the ukrainians with what they need to
push back against us and restore the
very deterrence that America had just 24
months ago I saw you in a Twitter Battle
of sorts
um with the head of the teachers union
and in something you said and she
responded and
um Randy Weingarten and I was wondering
was that designed to say I get domestic
policy too
no I I spent most of my life raising a
family and running a machine shop in
Wichita Kansas that's my life and then
serving as a member of congresswear
dealt with energy and AG issues and
education issues that's everyone knows
me as a CI director and the Secretary of
State but that's where I frankly spent
most of my life was on things that
matter here at home and I just watched
this debate about what was taking place
in our schools where we closed them down
for covid and I have long known that the
Kansas Teachers Union was bad for
students in Kansas I worked on this
before I lost my mind and ran for
Congress and so I was I was simply
remarking on the fact that Randy
Weingarten has destroyed the education
for kids Across America and over the
last couple years it's actually hurt the
least amongst us the most and that makes
her really dangerous because if you
if you don't regenerate a nation with an
understanding of our founding if you
teach them crap if you teach them that
we're a racist country and there's an
oppressor class in this country was
founded in a way that was ill-gotten and
we're the Bad actor in the world you
apologize for America that's what our
kids learn in school Brett
I don't know what the 72nd 73rd 74
Secretary of State's going to do he'll
be I was going to use an adult word
he'll be in real trouble uh because
America and our institutions depend on
people who know and appreciate the
greatness of our country and Randy
Weingarten has been at the center of
undermining that for decades this is a
podcast you can use whatever word you
want so um no I I saw that back and
forth and I I thought there was really
something because it does touch a lot of
families
um specifically because I dealt with it
especially during covid do you think you
know every time we go into an election
season especially presidential election
we think as as a former debate moderator
you know education should be up there
and then when push comes to shove we've
got all these different topics do you
think that this time education might be
higher on the on the totem pole
you know it's an interesting question
Brett your point on the history I think
is probably exactly right by the way it
wasn't the FCC with the bad word I was
worried about it was my mother uh
I I hope it is I hope it is in two ways
one in the end it's not the federal
government that really drives education
policy right it has a Bottoms Up deal
school boards uh ptas uh Boards of
Regents at you state universities Across
America those are the places where we've
really built educational Excellence for
decades in America but the federal
government can mess it up so I I do hope
that when we have uh debates for the
president I hope they will talk about
how the Department of Education is
mostly creating problems and not solving
them I hope it'll talk about the things
the federal government might do to make
that better to devolve that power back
to uh the people and to parents so that
they can teach their kids in a way that
is representative of their family and
their family's value set
um book is great never give an inch uh
fighting for the America I love uh
former Secretary of State former CI
director Mike Pompeo we appreciate the
time Brett thank you sir have a good day